I'd like to get a rife machine. I found your recommendation from three years ago here in the list of what rife machine do we recommend, a must have been a video or a web page that we talked about.
Are these still the factors to consider and the models you'd recommend things?
So I did not have time to, I don't know, really have time to research any of these questions you guys said in.
So I'm assuming that page talks about, I think I made a video a number years ago about some key points that I look at, I'm looking at the quality and effectiveness of a rife machine that I might have them in different order here.
The first has to be a light frequency. So rife is frequency medicine, rife is using frequencies to try to help your body heal.
And one of my qualifications in a rife machine, because there's a lot of rife machines out there, rife is just the name of royal rave and rife.
So anybody could say they have a rife machine and it could be a whatever, right.
So there's a lot of rife machines out there that are frequency generators, but they're using electrical frequency or they're using sound frequency.
Well to me that's not what I at least would define a rife machine, rife machine is using light frequency.
That's what's going to be right, light is different than sound is different than electrical, though they all have their benefits electrical frequency could be great for muscular skeletal issues.
Sound frequency can be good for joint issues and fluid issues, but light frequency light is a different waveform light is a photon carried on the waveform and it has different properties and it affects the cellular structure differently.
And royal rife found that using light frequency, especially with dealing with cancer, dealing with organisms that you're trying to kill like pathogens.
That was the best thing to use it in my experience, using rife since the late 90s now going on 25 years.
I've used just about everyone out there. So first of all, qualify it in my definition of a rife machine, it has to use light frequency.
And then secondly, it has to have enough amperage. That's what's pushing the frequencies out in order for it to penetrate your body.
So if you're using light frequency, but it doesn't have enough power, the machine doesn't have enough power for the frequencies to penetrate your body.
It's useless, it's not doing anything. And then third, it has to be programmable.
So if it comes with a set of frequencies for, you know, that are really simplistic and you can't program it for what that patient needs.
And its use is going to be, is going to be, you know, minor because you're dealing with somebody that has, okay, let's just use hpilori, for example, that's a gram negative bacteria.
If you don't have a hpilori, you know, different frequencies, there's, there's dozens of frequencies that have been found to help kill hpilori.
But if your rife machine only has one frequency for bacteria or something that, most likely it's not going to be dealing with, you know, the right frequency to kill hpilori, you could run it, tell your eyes turned green, but you're not going to, it's not going to effectively do anything for you.
So it has to be programmable so that you can program it specifically for your needs, that you can add frequencies that are, that are committed to greater knowledge through practitioners that you can add more things, otherwise, you know, it's, it's not working.
And then lastly, it has to be the user friendly. So if it's not really easy to use, just like any piece of exercise equipment, you're not going to use it.
So I'd hate to have somebody buy a rife machine, it might be really powerful, it might be really good, it might even be programmable, but it's really kind of complicated to turn on. And because of that, they don't use it.
Well, you know, use something, even if it's the greatest thing in the world, it's not going to work.
So we have settled on the true rife, I do think the GB 4000 fits those criteria as well, except that last one.
It's not as easy to use, it's definitely not as easy to use. And it's much more difficult to program. So that third one is an issue, but it is very powerful and I like it.
I actually have one behind me, but I have a true rife right front of me here, too. So the true rife is the one that we use.
Because of those criteria, the other one comes in the market that's I think better than I'll switch to that. But right now, yes, answer your question, those models I recommend.
So if people call us and want to buy a rife issue, they're getting a true rife.
So that as far as I'd like to buy a rife issue, you can't just buy one right off our store.
I don't recommend that and I might not sell it to you. So if it will, that's mean, what do you do that for?
Well, I mean, what I mean is, if you're going to buy a rife issue for, I want to work best for you.
So I got to get to know you. We need to do a case review and know what your needs are for me to program it for your needs.
So set up a case review is what you want to do.